my first guest you know him from his
comedy central special he's got a sketch
special with kami central with the soma
naj
called goat face please welcome the very
funny fahim anwar
how are you thank you hold for applause
hold on talk about your career or
whatever
i know hey how do we survive in this
coped world in these uncertain times
moses
i don't know it seems like you kind of
knew how to pivot immediately you do a
lot of online
videos yeah kind of like uh i think you
as a comedian too it's like stand up is
our main jam
and then we have these other outlets
like all right i'll do a dumb thing on
instagram or i'll do a tweet and
once the stage is gone i guess you're
just kind of leaning into what's still
available
yeah because the stage i think it still
kind of works if you're a one-liner guy
but i think you
and i i mean you on a much higher level
are very physical performers a lot of it
is like
in your body which you can't really do
totally and it's a conversation with the
audience so it's like if they're really
liking something
that informs you go oh let me milk this
so it's this song and dance with an
audience and that kind of informs your
act
so when you strip an audience away
you're kind of creating in a vacuum
and that's tough for a for a stand-up
live performer yeah because like a
musician where you just play your
three-minute song
stand up if you're doing it right when
you get beyond like out of your head and
you're
doing it long enough you're essentially
asking the audience for permission
every 15 seconds or so to be like can i
keep talking yeah
yeah yeah dick made dick sucks yeah
so you've seen my new stuff yeah i've
seen it um hour
it was about to come out we were about
to take it was gonna be called my dick
sucks and we had
like msg we had that rent out
it was gonna be three nights yeah my
dick sucks and that's not my big
catchphrase
oh my god but now it's like on hold
oh and then you had you had a merch
already printed out
yeah my dad have so many boxes of my
dick sucks and i don't know where to put
it i have some of it in my place right
now and it's not going to make sense
when things open up
and my
it's a false narrative it's completely
healed since the accident
totally i mean it is a there's some very
sad options like i was talking about
top i mean you could perform it about
you did the truck show huh yeah it's the
best
version i heard it's good i got asked to
do it but i was
i think i was in denver for that weekend
or whatever but i hear it's great
oh yeah you were uh you were in a
covid's fake protest in denver i forgot
about it yeah yeah
no i did some charity gig i did some
like charity gig
and it was in a it was an airplane
hangar and they were all in tuxedos it
was just like upper crust denver
i swear to god it's like i was doing
stand-up in a bond movie insane at the
airport i don't know all the hell gigs
are things that we're
essentially competing for like yeah
absolutely airport hangout who books
that
like the tallest ceilings like you know
the best thing for comedy is like in a
basement
low ceilings packed together this was a
hanger
just like the the voice just evaporates
they're sitting so far away from each
other
but they said they were still happy yeah
it's like what what can you do
sometimes i think about stand-up comedy
in the in yesteryear that we were just
a distraction to shovel food and drinks
into people's mouths yes
like we were there to keep them in the
seats long enough to
pull up a dump truck and put it in their
mouths yeah people wonder like what
why why do you do 45 to an hour of
material because that's how long it
takes
to order a drink some food and then
another room
yeah that's that's what this art form is
no painting
you know that i'm like yeah totally and
i love how
nimble this art form is too where like
if they're a little
late to putting the checks out on the
table they'll tell you to like
they'll go like this you know like go
along stretch it out
and then you just you know do some more
[ __ ] for 10 more minutes until
everyone
signs their checks nothing else you
couldn't do that like with a magician
be like keep more magic
more cards just get more yeah more decks
just the magicians just vamping just
trying to make some tricks on the fly
yeah that's why i feel like ugh it was
cringe when people make the argument
like let me say this is free speech and
it's like
it's really it's chicken wing speech
it's just long enough the thing is i
think there is that free speech thing
and you should be able to but
it's up to you to jump over the hurdle
of making it
funny for the room if like people are
turned off all the time you haven't done
the work
yeah the real trick in the beauty of
stand-up is taking that controversial
idea or whatever your idea is
and doing the gymnastics and massaging
it enough
where it's it's digestible for even
someone who has a posing view
like bill burr will do that all the time
and it's great like
they earn the laugh you can still get
your idea across you just gotta do the
work
instead of like free speech man you
don't like it
people confuse just bombing with people
that like free speech
yeah like you didn't your writing wasn't
good enough don't pretend you're bill
hicks or something
right i don't need structure i'm
screaming about or
they don't get it like you're part of
the problem no just
right write a little more if you're
doing your job they should get it they
should get it and like it
so does everyone in your life know that
you have all this time off you're not
performing
on stage like are your parents being
like hey why are you living out there do
you want to come
home i have this thought like uh you get
a sense of
how much your parents really believe in
you by how quickly
they tell you to get into real estate
you know what i mean to like start
selling houses
yeah like for me it was like it was like
a few days like corona yeah the shutdown
like a week later like you should sell
houses like oh you never believed in me
i'm finding out now and i always like
how that's the solution for
like parents everywhere it's just like
if your kid was like kind of a [ __ ] up
to begin with
they're gonna kill it in the real estate
market like suddenly they're gonna be
awesome if someone can't be a comedian
and monster that can work for 15 minutes
a night and post some instagram clips
one of the odds are gonna be free on a
sunday for an open house
sure you think they're gonna be on
selling sunset like hey thanks mom and
dad i was spinning my wheels with this
art stuff but now i'm a world-class real
estate agent
i'd love to show you some properties
like he's probably gonna suck at that
too
right there's no way the women are
selling cents that are actually selling
those properties
i wouldn't buy a house after that very
quick walk through where they're also
having a
huge fight i'm like well that's the
house for me
yeah i don't i don't know like they all
look the same like do you have to be
gorgeous to sell houses
i think in la for selling that because
it could be like just
so i want to show you some properties
there's um there's one on mulholland
it's it's got this open floor plan
you're gonna love it
okay all right and take my car
take my car you know talk it over with
your wife you don't want to make a rash
decision i'm not trying to pressure you
but
i'm one of the best and you live in this
area well i do mostly stuff in uh
torrance but they gave me a shot at the
big time here on sunset one of the one
of the women from the show
you know one of the you know they're
busy they're busy right now that's why
they sent me to show you the property
um it's the same property it's just a
different person showing it to you
my ford focus i gotta put money in the
meter real quick um i'll be back
he's at the bottom of sunset all the way
down the hill
can you give me a ride to my car i've
got to put money in my meter for my ford
focus
soaking wet dude that's what i noticed
too like if you're a real estate agent
you have to
even if you're not doing well you have
to lease a bomb ass car
it's all exuding this even if you're
really good at what you do you can't
drive like a honda fit yeah you gotta
show up
because you're selling an image and a
lifestyle and you're like yeah i want my
guy to be cut throat
right you need to make people feel like
[ __ ] about their
life or just like oh man this guy he
deals with high society or i'm
i'm visiting this world or he's going to
get me the best
like you don't want a practical like you
do but you want the fantasy of this
armani suit lamborghini real estate
agent not the hell that i live in
showing up in it honda yeah you're like
this guy looks like me
i could just go on redfin right this
guy's like
a brokerage deal for me he came cleaning
empty gatorade bottles out of his car
you ever taken an uber ride where they
go like yeah just like shove it over
yeah just push it over hey you had one
job like
you're not my friend doing me a solid
this is a transaction like
hey just push those roller blades over
[Music]
hey commit to the job sizes spaghetti
that's built back there well what i love
about taxi drivers
is like they knew they were a taxi
driver they accept they're like
yes i drive people around and you know
like this is my life i like doing it and
there was a clear distinction but people
ubering and lyft sometimes they're in
denial they're like yeah i'm just doing
this for a few weeks until
yeah just shove it over they gotta tell
you that immediately that this isn't
their job no other job is like this
isn't my job by the way which is not
reassuring when someone's in charge of
your life
you're up in a helicopter like listen
this is just my side gig my real passion
is children's modeling
just so you know i i don't enjoy doing
this but where where are you headed to
i am i am one foot out the door i'm not
even here for this job
i miss like because because with the
stars you know how you rate each other
everyone's on the best behavior because
you can still
be affected there's a beauty to taking a
taxi you can like clip your toenails in
the back
and there's no repercussions whatsoever
it'll never come back to you you may be
paying a premium
but you can be like you know [ __ ] your
mother yeah what are you gonna do about
it
and like you have no stars to be yeah
that's what you like to do you're in the
back seat rock
yeah i just no no it's not a sexual
thing it's more of a power dominance
thing
okay i just berate them and i clip my
toenails
and i go what are you gonna do you can't
rape me
toenails don't even need to be clipped
you're just like really down to the bone
yeah yeah you look great man i feel like
look this isn't the most high-res
but i feel like you have great skin yeah
there's several filters on this
yeah remember when michael jackson would
get interviewed he would have his own
lighting team
to look like a human like when martin
beshear was doing like that documentary
or whatever
yeah they showed this set like they had
several scientists
bouncing light to to make it look
like a human face just burst
yeah i love mj but it was so funny to
think like
you know it had been carved up so much
that he needs this
the lighting like this so that the
shadows can kind of
fill in for the gaps yeah it always
looked like a gas leak was happening
like the air is wavy
everyone's about to pass out yeah martin
beshear's like
michael um in the 80s
all right can i do it like a quick dance
just for my fans real quick
yeah it's what they tune in for do the
full thing
it's great that the whole apartment
shakes when you dance well you're on a
sofa so
and we are we are in la so there are
earthquakes we had one a few weeks ago
very important very important that we
stay here while it burns
and it's on fire and there's no
opportunities here but hey
quibby could be around the corner come
on quibby i need that quibby cash this
section of my house is on fire but i
will not
leave until i get a fitting for quirby
yeah man it's worth it all right so
people can find you at fahim
anwar you're been on the joe rogan
podcast a couple times
a lot of people think from that and then
um uh your podcast you guys started back
up again
called dance yeah he-man or dance hour
so that's on spotify apple all that
stuff and then i'm on instagram at the
ximenwar
um oh yeah my special my one hour
special it's free on youtube comedy
central put it out
it's called there's no business like
show business so
check out a free hour of stand up well
thank you so much man for talking to me
yeah man it was good seeing you and it's
cool to do something during all this you
know i know it's nice to have a thing to
do
i'll see you in a parking lot okay i'll
see you on the circuit
i'll see you on the circuit there are
everyone peace